[Music]
[Music]
what
is this place what's your name honey
uh i'm joel i teach middle school band
connie go for it
today started out as the best day of my
life
back here tonight first shows at seven
yes
you know what that's gonna say joe
gardner
i did it i got the gig
must have been sudden for you
oh my god
no it's the great before this is where
new souls get their personalities quirks
and interest before they go to earth
meet 22. i don't want
okay look i already know everything
about earth and i don't want anything to
do with it
you're missing out on the joys of life
like uh pizza
i can't smell we can't we can't taste
either all that stuff is in your body
no smell no taste or touch see
okay i get it
wow it's my life
is all this living really worth dying
for
you're still alive can you help me get
back
no way
[Music]
[Music]
what is it 151 000 souls going to the
great beyond every day
and i count every single one of them the
count's
off huh
i love my life i love you so much gary
i'll never forget the day we met
ready hello little snail what's your
name
scary huh do you want to be friends
me too gary
i'm home gary gare bear
gary gary have you seen gary
nope nope gary's been snail mapped
[Music]
this summer the search begins friends
don't let friends go on dangerous quests
[Music]
with all new faces
hello call me sage good night i'm made
out of sage
and i am a sage so it works out pretty
well i'm patrick my name means
toaster in celtic pretty sure it doesn't
the most amazing places
the lost city of atlantic city boy i
hope we don't lose focus
look i wouldn't worry about us losing
ice cream
and a hero let it ride patrick let it
ride
you can bet on put it on l
patrick that's not an l that's a seven
seven starts with an l
that's weird the spongebob movie
sponge on the run this is gonna be like
a buddy movie oh i love your sense of
irony patrick thank you
i love my sense of ironing too
[Music]
are you ready this is the main event
he's coming
come get some of this uh-huh
who wants a selfie tentacular
i've got your whole life story tattooed
on my body
yeah in a long history of monster
wrestling there has never been a
champion quite like centennial
fans around the world are asking is
there a challenger out there with the
hunger
the drive the discipline to become
the next champion
what all right i think that's enough for
today
steve might not look like much but there
is a champion monster inside of him did
he eat
thank you that felt great
[Applause]
we seriously need to work on strength
and endurance fortunately i know just
the things
[Music]
do it again
[Music]
oh boy this is my nightmare
[Music]
so what are you doing out here
there is a legend in the jungles of the
amazon
of a tree that heals all it could change
the world
but if it gets into the wrong hands he
could awaken
a great evil i believe that the legend
is real
and i'm gonna find it when i do just
imagine the lives that could be saved
i've been looking for this tree longer
than anybody
i've tracked the legend to every village
every island nothing
you're searching for something that
can't be found
you've never had the key let's do
something that's safe let's go see some
elephants there are no elephants in the
amazon and i don't even like elephants
lady everybody likes elephants
know this about the jungle everything
that you
see wants to kill you and can
careful they could smell fear i am not
afraid
oh my gosh who brings a submarine to the
amazon foyer
[Music]
hold on come on it i don't got it no no
no
no no no no just leave me alone that was
a disaster it didn't go the way i
planned
[Music]
is anyone hungry yeah starving i'm on it
i'm just going to wait until we get home
where the food isn't decomposing
well la dee da i didn't realize i was
with a bunch of sophisticates
families can come in all shapes and
sizes that's why i also feature having
some two-legged children
join them roll it imagine me and our
future children
frolicking this is fun i'm speeding up a
little
i'm speeding up quite a bit
i think he's getting the hang of it
tommy no those are mr mcgregor's
i swear if it wasn't for me peter just
leave my tomatoes alone you have
everything else honestly my kids will be
so much better behaved
on him as soon as they have a baby we're
done for
maybe we're better off without them
don't stare at the scenery rushing by
look at a fixed point on horizon and
just lock your eyes onto that
i love this place what's for lunch
there's a magical place with the ripest
radishes
the sweetest corn it's called the
farmer's market
and if you want an overpriced gift that
will never be used they shall have an
ascended bath bombs
this sounds a bit dodgy i would never
put you in danger
i promise okay i can't promise we're
gonna go and rob this place are you in
are you out
we're in run no
let them go my family's in trouble and
i'm gonna get them back
the other rabbits were taken and the pig
and the hedgehog
and the badger
let's go get the others why are you even
helping me
that's what a dad
[Applause]
[Music]
oh doesn't cottontail just discovered
sugar we had a good
run i'm gonna live forever
tell you
[Music]
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere why'd you bring me up here
entertainment value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate
that has no fault lines no fracking no
loud music
even is shaking on a daily basis
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
[Music]
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like a walking
dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the rebel of
his life
who are you
[Music]
call it fake
call it lock
call it karma
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
[Music]
katie used to be my little buddy go on
nature hikes
skip rocks
are you excited for camp don't make me
go
we used to be so connected hey dad smile
you know you could experience things a
whole lot better without that camera
that this is how i experience things
yes tomorrow i'm finally leaving for
college but in the meantime i made you
guys this goodbye video
you know what this is our last night
together how about we make 10 seconds
family eye contact starting put your
phone down now
no you're allowed to blink it's just eye
contact oh finally no screens at the
table
lindwhy are you kicking me i don't
understand i'm just gonna oh look i'll
watch it dad it's too late look i want
to watch it
uh dad this is exactly why i'm excited
to leave tomorrow katie
i know you can fix this
why do you need all that to take me to
the airport i canceled your plane ticket
to college
we are gonna drive you to school on a
cross-country road trip as a family
behold and now i present tricking rick
mitchell and
kiss me dang it katie hey dad can you
check the trunk yeah sure
dang it katie hey kids there's supposed
to be some great eggs around here this
is set down we hear a pound about to
drop our biggest invention yet
meet the helper box we promise you they
will never
ever turn even mom
what is that
greetings humans
technology rising up sayonara
robots roaming the streets what is this
strange creature
dog pig dog pig dog loaf of bread the
beetroots have always been weird
no time to wash your hands don't worry i
never do that's what makes us great
that's my girl then we just might be
weird enough
to save the world all right hands in
[Music]
oh who
is coming to my birthday party what
about rapunzel and don't tell me
she's getting her hair done nope writing
something called
a book sleeping beauty says she has
insomnia princess crew
that's a ship sir princess leia she's a
general now i demand glorious guests
then may i suggest inviting this young
lady
finally this horrible crone gets it
once upon a time to live a princess
named snow white
but this fairy tale is about to get
a whole new twist huh my shoes
get hurt
oh we need to find the most beautifulest
woman to kiss us
and reverse the curse after that it's a
witch let's catch her and make her break
the spell
one's where i can see a witch
oh my gosh what what happened to me i
mean my face and my waist
um is that really what i look like in
the mirror
i think i hit her too hard your power
has drained you
i don't have much time prince find her
why are they after you it's my shoes
yeah they're magical
attention idiots draws oh it's that
loser prince average voo
raj ah please charge
featuring the voices of chloe grace
morris sam claflin
gina gershon and patrick warburton i
can't wait for you to see the real me
i like you just as you are
you had a thing on your cheek
your true self you're amazing on the
outside and the inside
is the fairest of them all
this is where your fairy tale ends
up
i shall return on tuesday no wait i'm
gonna check my calendar
thursday you've got to be kidding me red
shoes and the seven dwarves
[Music]
it's been 147 days since the great flood
and only the animals lucky enough to
find a place on the ark
have survived it hasn't been easy with
no sign of land
what's this one same as
one it's a burnt pot of that one
this is all the food we have left huh i
need to make this food go a long
long way
dave where are the kids
[Music]
you're awake good you're a nest tree
i've never seen another nest i built
this colony to keep nestor and safe
from me dating beasts things are
different now they're the truth on the
ark
the ark it's landed oh boy here we go
shouldn't we help them what do you think
they'll be eating when the food runs out
rocks no not rocks you
you want us to go running into the jaws
of your carnivorous friends
if our time on the ark has taught us
anything and never
ever get into a tickle fight with a
hippo no dave
it has taught us that it is possible for
us animals to put our differences aside
[Music]
hey guys what did i miss only in cinemas
this october
[Music]
everything will stay the same cause the
dreams bring back all the memories
welcome to your new home
we're here what are you looking at
let's give him a great show okay i won
and only
why do they want an angry gorilla anyway
you're a silverback
he terrified humans oh
you're not terrifying
who's that my sister where's your sister
now
i don't remember memories never leave
us they just get out of reach
whoa did you draw all these a gorilla
who draws what is it don't tell me don't
tell me
it's a lonely haystack on a late
summer day
it's a beetle can you tell me a story
once there was a baby elephant who was
smart and brave
and she needed to live in the wild where
she could be free
does the baby elephant get to be free
[Music]
this painting is clearly a sign he wants
to be free
what about mac he's taking care of me my
whole life we're family
we're in this together
[Music]
for one and only even
[Music]
i'll just cross the road then why would
you cross the road
to get to the other side
oh it's about to start ready ready
popcorn button
nachos cheese repair with red licorice
straw right here
maybe it's time we made our new movie
good idea scoob
but first we need a trailer oh can you
do the trailer guy voice
hmm well let me give it a shot
in a world destroyed by evil
discover the epic origin story
the greatest team of heroes
[Music]
nailed it
hey this mangy strays coming with me
he's not a stray
okay then what's his name his name's
scooby middle name doobie last name
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh never take it off
maybe don't do that again
i'm fred this is velma hi and that's
daphne hey i'm shaggy
and this is scooby doo nice to meet you
[Music]
shaggy and scooby were taken
do you realize where we are no look
around man
the clean modern aesthetic the cool blue
color palette
we're in mikey falcon fury did you say
ikea nope
i said falcon terry just like you
maybe this can lead us to scooby and
shaggy trace amounts of mustache oil
12 year old scotch is the bad guy my
dad
[Music]
candice every day you call and tell me
phineas and ferb have built some big
unbelievable things and every day i come
home to find
nothing there doesn't it exhaust you it
exhausts me
oh look there's nothing here
okay guys i give up what does this one
do
uh candace
where are you going where is she going
candace got abducted by aliens and taken
to another planet
when we step through this portal we're
going to be on an alien planet
hello and welcome aliens giant robot
quick kiss that's just norm he's he's
usually
harmless if we're going to rescue
candace we need to build a spaceship my
galactic travelinator
you mean like a spaceship but it's an
anatomy there's a difference
it's branding leave me alone verb i know
we're gonna do today
we have to
[Music]
okay that was something i did not know
we need to find where they're keeping
[Music]
candice
i know what we're gonna do today it's
me against the universe
happy birthday mr adult man oh my god
what was dad like his beard was scratchy
he had a goofy laugh
i wish i'd met him i have something for
you
from your dad it's a wizard staff
i wrote this spell so i could see for
myself who my boys grew up to be
this spell brings him back back like
back to life
he wanted to meet you more than anything
bully tooth of zadar how did you i don't
know it just started
we've only got 24 hours to bring back
the rest of dad
we're going on a quest
all quests start with the manticore the
fearless adventurer you mean
corey she's over there quick somebody
help me these griffin nuggets were
supposed to go out minutes ago that's
the man's decor you guys are in trouble
big
time get in the vehicle i'm escorting
you home i'm giving you to the count of
three
uh okay wait what are you doing i don't
know
i'm looking for my sons oh they went on
a quest but don't worry i told them
about the map i told them about the gym
i told them about the curse
huh i forgot to tell them about the cars
what
your boys are in great danger
hold on
[Applause]
how are you boys doing a crisis oh no
we're dead we're dead we're dead not
great
i can't do it we're not gonna see you
dad you can do this
i believe in you my gut knows where to
go don't you boy yes you do
i'm on my way boys just stay out of
[Music]
trouble
the man oh no
this isn't about the father this is
about the sun
heart miss fowl
[Applause]
you've grown strong son
and smarter than i ever imagined
then take me with you you're all i have
now arty
there's just one very important thing i
have to do
[Music]
authorities launched a worldwide manhunt
for the famous collector
he is suspected to have been behind some
of the biggest robberies ever
dad
hello your family has taken something of
great value from us
return it to me or i will destroy
everything you love you weren't supposed
to see this yet
your father is in a complicated
profession for years
he has protected powerful secrets that
have kept mankind safe
from the dangers of another world it's
time to face your destiny
this is what they call greatness but we
are not alone in this
mulch just a talented giant dwarf and
i'm holly short
your ally on the other side
it's real
all right save my father save the world
hope team ready tell them we are dead
an army is coming
i didn't read much on trolls anything i
should look out for the teeth
they eat people good to know
you are not going to get away with that
jake
no good night good night dad
you're behind your dream stage it's
completely off-limits for all dreamers
the dream stages are real wow you can
actually change people through their
dreams
why did they have to move in with us
don't you want to be a real family again
[Music]
there's literally no insta here
[Music]
nice
tomorrow i'll make sure my mom removes
that thing i always get what i want
three two one don't wake me up she wants
to put my hamster in an animal shelter
maybe i could tinker a tiny little bit
with her dreams
well that was a lot of shambles i mean
how am i supposed to whack in this heat
these conditions
tonight we're starting our way back to
earth i can't wait i'm gonna see my
friends again
an asteroid field we may be separated
for a little bit son
hello mr william i am your personal
survival module for cases of emergency
landing on an unknown planet
uh hello i'm an explorer
and i have to take pictures of
everything i find
the pot contains everything necessary
for survival
hey hello
[Music]
why'd you do that the biggest creatures
are not always the dangerous ones
sometimes they are run
climb aboard mr william
alert battery level low so i'm going to
have to leave you for a while what
don't worry i won't let you down rely on
mr flash he knows this planet quite well
what are you guys going to get me
[Music]
shall i tell you a story
[Music]
it's the story of an orphan girl
it was sent to live in a mysterious
house
if you caused me trouble i'll have you
sent away in an instant you understand
unless you discovered something
something magical
something secret but let me start at the
beginning
my name is mary lennox and my uncle owns
this house i'm colin craven and the
uncle you speaking is my father my
cousin
when's the last time you used your chair
i've never been able to walk we could go
outside
who knows you might feel better who are
you
i'm digging i need you to keep a secret
if you are too much of a lady there is
no
am no lady son
[Music]
to know of a magical place capable of
extraordinary things i'd say that you're
lying
do you trust me you know what you risk
it's worth the risk
magic is on our side once
this house was filled with lights
laughter
happiness this garden
needs to cure colin
your excitement could kill him colin
needs to live this house is
[Music]
it's beautiful magic
secrets
[Music]
the yukon is a dangerous place
you never know what's coming
i came up here because i didn't want to
be around
anyone and then i met
buck
he was a dog like no other
you've been spoiled
[Music]
and he'd suffered come on
but it could not be broken
i don't know where you came from but i
know where you are now
welcome to the last place on the earth
should let him have a minute
doesn't look like he's ever seen snow
before
how do you feel about an adventure
beyond all maps we could go
you and i where no one's ever been
before
see what's out there
[Music]
i'm glad you're enjoying this
i never saw him believe in anything as
much as he believes in you
[Music]
what do you say book
adventure of a lifetime
he was sleeping for two days in my bed
in a world full of hidden danger
one secret team of super spies watches
our tales please say the password
beethoven incorrect uh scooby doo
garfield
you got it sister seriously i put in a
request
how was the night shift all dad well
back's a little stiff
ah roast beef um i'm not gonna even ask
what the feline is that i am the most
nefarious villain the world has
ever seen this is not good
take to the skies
getting closer boss
we are getting reports of global unrest
developing in the pet world
we don't stop this now it could lead to
an all-out war between cats and dogs
bottom line this starts and ends with
you two
just need a minute when evil strikes
soon they will feel what it is like to
be
unwanted
we're gonna need a crew heroes unite
this clyde in 6d
he wears a diaper he could track
someone's scent from a mile away
doggy diaper nuff said anastasia leopold
maximus worms fleas explosive diarrhea
and that's just anastasia we need
qualified dependable specialists
are we robbing a casino to catch a
criminal mastermind
rates breaks oh no a roundabout
maybe i should take over they'll sniff
out the clues spill the beans purse
pooch
you think it was too much and never
oh
roll over
oh dear god we're doomed cats and dogs
three
paws unite
what do they do you should notice your
disdain for one another begin to wear
off
oh your coat is so soft
on dvd blu-ray and digital
[Music]
you